[音楽]
こちらは福沢
諭吉の顔が書かれた紙切れです皆さんこれ
欲しいですか
ありがとうございます私も欲しいです
でもこれ
この紙そのものに
価値が内在しているとは思えないだって
食べられないし
まともな燃料にもならない
こっちはどうですか
いらない
あーそっか
残念です
一体何が違うでしょう
この違いとは
自分の次にそれを受け取ってくれる人間が
いるかどうか
です他の誰かが受け取ってくれるに違い
ないこの
期待こそがお金の正体ですみんながそう
期待すれば
紙切れはお金として社会が流誰もが喜んで
それを受け取るそのうち人々は
これそのものに価値が内在すると錯覚し
出す
僕らは
価値あるものとしてこれを受け取りますで
も根源的には受け取るというこの行為こそ
が
紙切れに価値を与えているんです
こうやって僕たちは社会の中で生活し
ながら同時に無意識のうちに社会そのもの
を作り出してい
ますさて
ここからが今日の本題です
近代社会は個人の自由を尊重します
人間には自分の未来を選び取る力がある
個人はその自由意志を発揮して
自分の行動と将来が決定戦
でもちょっと待ってほしい
自由ってどこにあるんですか
だってこの脳みそが
物理法則の奴隷じゃないんですか
一体どこに自由があるんだどうやって僕ら
は自分の未来を自分で決めるんでしょう
ところでこれはメルカトル図法の世界地図
なんですが
グリーンランドとサウジアラビアやって
だいたい同じ面積でやってたとご存知でし
た
それから
東京と
ニューヨークを最短距離で結ぶとこうなり
ます
歪んでますね
だいぶ笑顔が出ます3次元の地球を2次元
に無理やり単純化するからこんなことに
なるんですよ単純化は
歪みを生み出します
自由というのも世界が単純化する装置です
例えば人々の所得はいろんな要因で決定さ
れます
生まれた地域
良心の所得顔
身長テストで考えたかどうかこれらを全て
無視して
個人が所得要素の人の自己決定に還元する
この社会的装置こそが自由ですつまりあの
人がたくさん稼いでいるのは彼が自分の
意思で努力したからだっていう論理ですね
これは
恐るべき単純回数
ですから当然
歪むんです社会構造に依頼する
貧困が個人の問題に還元されてしまいます
彼は健康なのは彼自身の選択のせい
だつまり彼の責任だ
そもそも近代社会ってのは平等が建前です
から
格差の原因が社会構造にあると思われちゃ
いけないんですよ
隠蔽する仕組みが必要だ
現実を単純化してゆがめて
貧困の責任を個人に押し付けてこうやって
格差を正当化する仕組みこそが近代社会に
おける自由です
それだけじゃ
ない格差は人々に恐怖を与え
努力すれもしないもうどうぞご勝手にただ
初代は自己責任だよ
こうして近代社会は
競争社会になっていく
僕らは現在の欲望を押し殺して今の苦しみ
が将来の幸せにつながると信じて競争する
これが苦しいからこそ
未来は自分次第だと信じたくなる
僕らが他の紙切れに価値を作り出すように
僕らは自分自身の中に自由を作り出す
この熾烈な競争に勝ったものは
幸せな人生を自分で掴み取ったと高らかに
宣言するわけです
このようにして自由という虚構は人々を
空虚な競争へと駆り立て
少女と敗者を作り格差を制動化するこの
格差が
脅さなくてさらに
競争が加速するこんな社会でなお人々は
デビューを信じてやら
私は決して自由がない社会の方がいいと
言っているわけじゃありません
そもそも人間は物理的に自由じゃない
本当に自分で未来を選べることと
選べると感じることこれは別問題ですこれ
は混同してしまったのが人材社会と言える
でしょう
そうじゃなきゃ自由を求める革命連携起き
ませんから
社会は歪んでいます僕らはこの社会を
作り出しながらしかしそれには気づけない
お金
自由国家個人
歴史あらゆるものが僕らのゆがんだ価値観
を産物です
社会問題があっては同じです
自分の価値観に沿って現実を作り
価値観に沿って理想を作り出す共に
ギャップが社会問題ですから
まあこれは価値観の塊と言っていい
例えば
環境汚染これが社会問題になったのは
せいぜい60年代以降で年を
産業革命からずっと僕らは
自然の浄化作用を超えて環境を汚染してき
たわけですがそれは400年もの間問題に
はならなかった
もっと身近な例で言えばDVや体罰なんか
も40年前は問題じゃなかったわけ
です社会問題っていうのは客観的にそこに
あるものではありませんあくまでも僕らが
僕らの価値観でもって作り上げるもの
ですよく社会問題の解決を目指すとか言い
ますけど
この問題設定を間違えてしまうと
むしろ世界を滅ぼせかねないというのが
わかりますよね
ですから自分自身の価値観をよく知る必要
があります自分はどう世界を見ているのか
どう社会を解釈しているのかこれをよく
知る必要があるんです
何なんだけどこれはとてつもなく難しい
なぜなら価値観というのは物を考えるため
の基盤だからですこの目と同じです
僕は自分の目を通して世界を見る
なんだけどこの目を直接はできることは
できない同様に自分の価値観を直接は
分からないん
ですだからこそ他者を介して
自分を知る必要があります
友達と会話する自分とは違う立場の人の話
を聞く
社会学や人類学を学んでみる何だっていい
ただ他者を知ることなしに自分を知ること
ができません
自分の価値観の輪郭が
異なる価値観との違い対比を通してのみ
浮き上がってきます
自分とは違う価値観をまず発見し
それを理解しようとすることで初めて自分
の価値観が絶対じゃないことを知るん
です社会っていうのは僕らが思ってるより
もずっと複雑でなんだけど
それは本当の仕組みを外して単純化され
歪められた姿で私たちの前に姿を現します
ですから社会に
騙されないでください
社会の中でのことを考えるんじゃなくて
社会そのものを
捉えようとすること自分の中でものを
考えるんじゃなくて自分そのものを
捉えようとすること
地獄への道は
善意で敷き詰められています
皆さん
良かれと思って世界を滅ぼさないで
くださいね
以上ですありがとう
[拍手]